well that's the Sun devouring father
that's a painting by Modena of Satan
it's pretty horrifying one and that's
Captain Hook I really liked the figure
of Captain Hook some of these popular
mythological stories myth based fairy
tales modern fairy tales I've got things
really right Captain Hook well he's a
pirate so I think I told you that in the
Google engineers investigations of
female sexual fantasies the pirate
played a large role war wolf vampire
pirate surgeon billionaire incredibly
comic comical well pirate you know
captain of the high seas and someone
willing to break rules there's a romance
in that figure well so the idea of the
great father as the pirate is a good one
Welker hook is kind of a pathetic pirate
and of course Pirates are precisely that
because they're also crooked and so what
makes him pathetic well it isn't because
he's got a hook precisely because maybe
that's just a sign of adventure it's
because he's being chased by a crocodile
with a clock in its stomach well that's
the dragon of chaos right that's time
tick tick tick
your life is gonna end it's already got
a piece of you and it's coming for the
rest and so Hook is terrified of that
he's terrified into resentment and and
and evil roughly speaking why he could
prey on other people and so that's the
father in the Peter Pan story out in
Neverland which is the archetypal domain
Captain Hook's the father well why would
Peter Pan want to grow up to be Captain
Hook well he doesn't and so he stays
pan-pan means everything right
like pantheism he stays everything he's
this divine child he never wants to grow
up well why would you sacrifice the
potential of youth to become nothing but
a death-obsessed
tyrant well that's the story in in Peter
Pan and of course Wendy's in this story
and so is Tinker Bell Tinker Bell is the
imagined feminine she's just she doesn't
even exist she's just this perfect
little thing that's always around
whatever Peter Pan needs her but the
problem with Tinker Bell is that she's a
fairy and fairies don't exist
he has Wendy there she's a real girl
she grows up and actually marries
someone Peter Pan stays king of the Lost
Boys forever and you know maybe it's
better to be king of the Lost Boys but
then not to be king at all but maybe not
to king of the Damned is not exactly
something to snot a dominance hierarchy
to strive for dominating so that's the
Peter Pan story and it's a right it's
the right story for the modern age
that's for sure so that's a negative
element of the Great Father there's a
positive element of the Great Father
these are both red this is a
representation of Moses receiving the
the the rules for living from God on
high what we talked about that already
you know and I see that that's a story
of the revelation of structure that's
the story of mankind we're acting out a
moral structure well what is it now and
then we get a glimpse of what the moral
structure isn't it hits people with the
force of a revelation then it can be
articulated and that's partly what the
story of Moses lays out and you see here
this picture I really like this one too
this is a supplicant basically someone
who's who's hit hard by a divine vision
it's God in heaven again very very
similar to this with with the cross in
the background and it's something like
to transcend your littleness because
look he's looking up that's what's at
the top of the dominance hierarchy it's
what at the top of all possible
dominance hierarchies look up that's the
father who supports the Sun that's
transcending his own vulnerability right
willing to bear it voluntarily and not
to and not to shirk from that it's
exactly right and it is what you admire
in people you know you admire people who
are courageous and who were strong and
when you decompose that it means that
they're able to act appropriately and in
a helpful compassionate wise and tough
manner despite the fact that they're
beset with all of the problems of
mortality that beset everyone else well
how does it go wrong well that's all
propaganda for Hitler you look at the
imagery you know he's a knight that's on
the right he's that he's the knight of
nationalism well that's God the Father
too you know it's a little bit one-sided
right
because there's more to the farther than
the state that's the thing and that's
the problem with nationalism and its
totalitarian variants and we're moving
in the direction fast right you see
Europe right now fragmenting again
because the European Union is too
amorphous and maybe not well enough
bordered and everyone is getting nervous
and they're saying back to the state
back to the state it's fair enough fair
enough you you need to be around people
who are like you so to speak that you
have built a consensus with but to
subordinate yourself to the state and to
make its head the the bearer of the the
the archetype of the night without
having that element of individuality at
it is absolutely pathological we've
already been down that road right
because the National Socialists were
hyper national just like well both in
Germany and in Italy and it's attractive
again it's interesting here you see
Hitler as a knight and up here there's a
bird you know and that bird should be
the Dove because that should be the holy
ghost if the iconography was proper but
it's not it's an eagle and an eagle is a
bird of carrion eater right it feeds on
corpses well it's worth thinking about
so that's the woman worshipping the
strong father another representation of
Hitler as a knight and then there's
Hitler as wise father you see he's
surrounded by people there who focused
in on him as if he's of architect
archetypal import and then this is a
poster from from the Allies an anti Nazi
poster from the Allies and you see right
there that Hitler and the Nazis are
assimilated to a mess of predatory
snakes it's like well why well if you
want to appeal to someone's
determination to destroy you say well
here you are and you're all ready to go
let's go kill some snakes and everyone
can say yes and then you say well
there's the snakes right there and the
thing is it's true to some degree
because you you have plenty of snakes
just like everyone else and so it's easy
that's the first step towards
demonization and you can do it just like
that it's no problem the archetype will
map perfectly especially if there's
already tension between the groups or if
the other group is identifiable in some
manner or you can make it identifiable
disgust is the best way to do that not
fear disgust fee
to fear someone you have to respect them
you don't want to burn everything that
the person that you fear owns you want
to burn everything that the person who
disgusts you owns and so you'll see
people who are pushing the nationalist
agenda hard and Hitler did this
beautifully everything that was outside
of the Aryan domain of purity wasn't to
be feared it was disgusting it was
contemptuous and it should be destroyed
and purified by fire and that was his
message the Nazis were unbelievably
great at using fire of purification as a
symbolic message well it has an
archetypal power and then you see here
this is an English poster from the world
war two asking people to buy bonds to
fund the American or the the British war
effort and you see these these telling
like Klaus Japan and Nazi Germany
reaching out to the Virgin Mother and
her infant child right the deep use of
deep subordination of archetypal imagery
for the purposes well I hesitate to say
propaganda because World War two in some
sense was a pretty clear-cut but you you
get the point
and there's the uniform reoccurred that
uniformity of the state right so the
goose step everybody moves exactly the
same way everybody's put everybody's
turned into exactly the same carbon copy
of everyone else all the diversity is
pushed out of the state its subordinated
to the supreme leader in the hierarchy
becomes incredibly rigid and and and and
and and and homogeneous it's like well
that's great for fast action but it's
terrible if you don't know where you're
going you need some diversity you need
some flaws in the cliff's crystalline
structure in case you're on the wrong
path and that's why you can't have
everyone being the Supreme Leader's
acolytes the whole bloody thing wanders
off in one direction and because we
don't know the right direction to go
wandering off in a single direction is
extraordinarily dangerous you will
eventually fall over a cliff so there's
the Nazis use of of light at night they
were unbelievably good at there at there
there's one of the things that made
fashion
so difficult to fight because with
communism because it was a fully
articulated philosophy you could attack
it rationally but fascism never really
did that what they did instead was used
ritual right huge mass rallies and
highly emotionally supercharged meetings
and then the use of light and fire and
so Hitler built the biggest parade
grounds in human history to host the
Nuremberg rallies and he would get in
front of them on this huge stage with
you know with Greek columns very
impressive looking and have blocks of
thousands of people organized perfectly
orderly the Germans are good at order an
order is associated with disgust
sensitivity incredibly organized orderly
displays complete and then at night with
fire and behind him he would have all of
the searchlights from the Luftwaffe
lined up dozens of them shooting their
lights straight up miles into the sky so
we stand in front of these incredibly
impressive displays of light long before
there were rock shows and so forth doing
that you know it was unparalleled in
history and and addressed the crowd and
he was very good at addressing the crowd
he'd say something and if people were
listening he'd say more of it and if
they were listening he'd say more of it
and because he was addressing the mob
the mob got exactly from Hitler what
they wanted and we saw what that was
like great 120 million people dead in no
time flat and the worst horrors that
were ever perpetrated on people maybe
because there's no shortage of
perpetrated horrors